how much value is there in getting these
endorsements okay so the weight of an
endorsement for example you get it from
a heavyweight politician a president a
media Mogul right you know like a Oprah
Winfrey or a musk or someone like that
or an entrepreneur hey Buffett a Bezos
and a musk or something like a Mark
Cuban or Triple Threat like a must
that's got all three sides influencers
but hey you know podcasts broken hey you
know Ben Shapiro hey you know uh uh all
these other guys that got their
influence Logan Paul even some of these
other guys that are doing what they're
because nowadays they're getting them
Hollywood stars like The Rock Dwayne
Johnson military General coming and
backing you up how much power and
influence is there in these types of
endorsement or is it just marketing it's
not really I think it depends it depends
on the person it depends on their
reasoning
um yeah it it really depends and and it
depends on you know I would say like Joe
Rogan for example he has a very
obviously hugely influential and is a
very loyal following and and uh he and I
you know he found I think over the last
few years especially how the things that
he says really do have a direct
impactful yeah
um you know I've also heard people say
uh you know that they candidates say
that they would shun an endorsement from
a Beyonce or a big celebrity figure
because that just has well you're just
one of those elitists who I can't relate
to as an everyday American and so that
actually ends up having even though you
know she's like the most powerful
talented musician singer in the world uh
I've heard candidates say well actually
no I don't want those kinds of
endorsements because it sends the wrong
message so you know I mean I think I
think every one of these things has
um its own you know pros and cons and I
don't think there's kind of a cookie
cutter uh impact some some are hugely
consequential and others not and others
have a negative consequence how much you
think a muscus by the way Jay-Z and
Beyonce just bought the most expensive
house in California in Malibu for 200
million dollars you just close it this
week wow it's a two-bedroom apartment
how much weight does that carry you
think it's a big weight especially for
somebody let's just say on the middle
center right
um I think it certainly carries weight
for people who who like what he's doing
and and who follow him I think it would
also you know how much weight does it
carry would depend on how much of his
own skin in the game he's if he just
says oh yeah I like this guy and then he
never says anything again has a
different uh has a different consequence
than him actually doing what you were
talking about in the beginning hey
you're a person of influence a person of
means if you really want to see this
change how much are you willing to put
your own skin in the game to actually
make it happen
got it so if he was let's just say to a
pack on Trump or whoever and he put up
or DeSantis whoever and he put up
something like a hundred million dollars
is that a way of others saying damn if
he's going like that with this person
there's got to be something we don't
know do you think that carries a very
big stick very big influence that would
that would make a big impact that would
make a big impact it's amazing what a
hundred million dollars would do these
days you know if it'll buy some
influence I mean Bloomberg tried to do
it it didn't do anything for him but you
know I'm just thinking about how much
these things because you know a lot of
people this person got endorsed by that
person this person got endorsed by that
person
I think Bloomberg though is is kind of
an example again I don't you know he was
running for president at the same time I
never got to know him at all but what I
saw on the ground was uh people were
very happy to take his money yeah didn't
mean they supported him didn't mean they
voted for him I thought you were gonna
say what I saw on the ground was a
six-inch lifter like this I'm sorry I
thought that's where you were going with
it and then you took a left turn I went
right my apologies was this 100 million
dollars for his own campaign or was that
okay gotcha because there's a big
difference between putting 100 million
dollars backing yourself versus yes and
Elon backing a DeSantis for example
there's a big difference yeah yeah no no
but I think no no he spent 100 million
dollars on biting guys he spent in
Florida no I I he spent a hundred
million dollars interesting
yes that's what I was I know he spent a
lot of money on himself but I'm talking
specifically with Biden so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign